okay can you hear me all right yes okay
good
hi everybody welcome to the last talk
for the day
and let's see what what we have in front
of us it's it's a full hour monologue on
technical debt I'm terribly sorry
everyone's at NDC talking about their
passions and I'm afraid this is this is
mine so my day job is working for NRK TV
NRK is the national public broadcaster
in Norway so basically if if you're in
the region and you're watching any of
our in our case productions using the
Internet you're using one of our
products yes so what is technical debt
so this is I'm gonna start a little bit
philosophically and then we're sort of
gonna just go on asking questions coming
up with some potential answers and then
just sort of going from there what is
technical debt and as sort of a backdrop
for that discussion I would like to
consider technical debt as a meme and
when I say meme I'm not talking about
like these internet memes that we're all
very familiar with like funny pictures
that are either original and or not that
original anymore so not these internet
memes but the concept of memetics which
was it's sort of a parallel to genetics
so it was proposed by Richard Dawkins in
his book The Selfish Gene as sort of a
similar mechanism to what's happening
with genes but at sort of the ideal
level so the idea is that you have
something called a meme which is a
self-replicating unit of thought and
this just like memes are copied from
person to person the denser copy from
person to person you have these memes
that are copying from brain to brain and
that means that it has some of the same
characteristics as you have routines
that there is sort of a scarcity there
variety and the good ones or the fit
ones survive and the other ones don't
Richard Brodie wrote a book called the
virus of the mind which deals with these
memes so then what makes a meme
successful so what is the sort of the
mechanism for survival of the fittest
when it comes to ideas and one sort of I
suppose positive angle you could take is
that the best ideas when the ones that
have the greatest explanation power very
different take is to think that it is
the ideas that are most effective at
reducing cognitive dissonance because we
know that we don't like cognitive
dissonance it makes us feel bad so in a
sense you have this tension between the
best ideas and the ideas that makes us
feel the best about ourselves and I
would like to have that thing as sort of
a backdrop for this discussion about
technical debt so what is technical debt
does anyone know who this guy is
what Cunningham here's the well he's
done a lot of innovations he's the
father father of the original wiki he
created CRC cards with Camp Tech and he
is also the man who came up with this
metaphor called technical debt and was
he originally said was that ship in
first time code is like going into that
a little that speeds development as long
as it's paid back promptly with rewrite
and the danger occurs so there is a
danger when the debt is not repaid and
every minute spent on not quite right
code comes counts as interest on that
debt and and this is quite dire entire
engineering organizations can be brought
to standstill under the debt load of an
uncounseled ated implementation so
that's already quite a rich metaphor and
it's sort of been reduced I think in a
lot of our minds into this single thing
called technical debt but there's not as
rich as this original
but okay so what are sort of the Sun of
the good good things about this metaphor
why is it a good metaphor well one of
the reasons I think it's a very good
metaphor is because it gives us language
to talk about something that's important
to us and it helps us put quality on the
agenda because one of the problems when
you write code is that the code is
invisible so it's very hard for people
who might have some interest in your
code to sort of see the issues that they
were talking about unless you have some
some language to sort of convey that
meaning so for that and for many other
things thank you to what it can occur
Cunningham for this for this great
metaphor now on the flip side what is
sort of a problematic what are the
problematic aspects with this metaphor
technical debt well one sort of obvious
thing is that if you have like real
monetary that it's easy to know how much
you have right you can you can ask your
bank how much was it again and they're
going to say like it's two million and
you say okay technical debt is not that
easily quantifiable I know there are
some efforts that some people try to
estimate how much technical that they
have and they get some measure I'm not
sure it's really technical debt that
they're measuring but something they are
certainly measuring but it's hard to
answer this question how big is your
technical debt and there are even worse
questions that you can ask are we even
technically solvent is it possible to go
tank technically bankrupt perhaps we've
already come technically bankrupt what
would I mean and to answer these
questions we sort of have to dig deeper
into what technical that really is and
we want to try to figure out what
something is you can try to see okay
what is it look like is it ugly code
I've been a program here I think for
something like 15 years or something at
least for money and I've seen some ugly
code some of it might be technical that
some might not be some of it makes me
look like this when I read it but that's
that's not very helpful in some sense so
maybe a better angle is it to sort of
look at what cost is technical debt and
if you ask your developer what cost is
technical debt you can get some theories
so what is this the mechanism that makes
the code ugly is it a lack of time other
people say we have technical debt
because of lack of time and it's sort of
pays back to the original formulation of
Ward Cunningham so you can sort of speed
up things for a little while by going
into that or is it that the project
manager Justin doesn't understand me
because it's not technical or is it that
the user experience people are
hopelessly unrealistic and they don't
know sort of the the cost of the
features that they propose alright I
suppose this is perhaps the the most
common one the previous developer was
really stupid well yeah what does it
look like well we can argue about this
but at least to me usually when I see
something that's classified as technical
debt what I see is a heap of flags and
branches and in directions and it's sort
of like these self-modifying
rollercoaster thing where you need to
set the right flags at the right time so
that you'll get through the right loop
to achieve the result that you wanted
and it's in general very difficult to
determine where something starts and
where it ends it's very hard to isolate
something that is related to a one
single victory and it's very difficult
to predict the effects of changes and in
general there is this problem that it's
hard to reason about the code it makes
your head hurt now these things what do
they indicate well is it that the
project owner doesn't understand
technology and it doesn't seem right is
it that the previous developer used the
wrong frame
for dependency injection or maybe that
we should have microservices instead of
the monolith or that would need a no
sequel database we should go to server
lists or that we should move everything
to kubernetes these are is all sort of
like technical solutions to some
problems but I'm not sure if there are
solutions to this problem so that was
supposed to be rhetorical questions so
hopefully it's obvious that no this does
not answer this question but there is it
is also obvious that there is something
that has gone very wrong and it's
something that has gone wrong in the
process of capturing the business domain
in software which is what we're trying
to do and if something has gone wrong in
understanding the business domain itself
and making and enforcing decisions and
finding some suitable representation of
your business domain in software and
what's more is we have a word for this
process and it's called modeling and
it's a very sort of like old school
ADIS sounding thing but that's what it
is
it is modeling that has failed and as
long as we're naming things what's the
name of the tool we use to contain and
conquer complexity in our code we have a
word for that as well
it's called abstraction now
unfortunately abstraction is sort of
two-edged sword so it's it also happens
to be the name of the tool we use to
create in compound complexity that's
abstraction too if we do it the wrong
way
so one perspective is that marbling is
the application of abstraction to a
problem domain but at the same time
modeling is also defining what the
problem domain should be I just have to
say this because modeling as opposed has
been given a bad name because of all
these sort of monster efforts upfront
sort of try to model everything down to
the class implementation detail before
you start sort of doing any
implementation so that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about
continuously working to understand and
articulate the problem you're trying to
solve and it's not just missing if this
is back to what Cunningham he said that
your voice to make the software reflect
your understanding as best you can so
this technical debt matter for is not an
excuse not to do modeling well so that's
that's one part one thing that's often
sort of not talked about when talking
about technical debt is how do we pay it
off how do we sort of get rid of it well
we do have an answer for that everyone
knows how to sort of pay back technical
debt and that's refactoring we can just
refactor it away now there are some
refactorings but it's it's not so easy
to sort of get at what refactoring you
should use when what you have is a tank
tangled mess of weak abstractions so
basically this is the catalog of
refactorings that refactoring comm and
they're all very low-level they're all
very close to the code and it's not
obvious how pushdown method is going to
help you sort of solve your problem with
weak abstractions and this is I think a
very good quote by Sarah Mae she said
that rewrite will end up with the same
problems as the original one unless you
close the understanding gap so what's
the understanding gap well in some sense
there isn't little purpose in doing
refactorings if you're not at the same
time doing remodeling so you sort of you
have to have some sort of goal what is
Marvel driven to where you're going with
your factoring I mean you can do sort of
small things without remodeling but for
sort of handling this sort of larger
improvement to to the abstractions in
your code these low level refactorings
is not going to do you very much good
and I think really that anything else is
just hubris on the part of us developers
so we have this tendency I think in the
industry to think that if we are just
sort of virtuous enough if we follow the
best practices well enough if we read
all the latest blog post we do all the
correct practices then these problems
will go away but I think reality is more
like this so you start out well but then
you sort of hit the brick wall and these
best practices are not enough and
unfortunately it would be very nice if
sort of these generic practices would be
sufficient to save your code but they
will not save you if you have a rotten
model if your understanding of the
business domain is insufficient how are
you going to sort of build the correct
abstractions to make the software
workable and viable in fact doing that
trying to sort of take these this code
base that's sort of soaked down in
technical debt and try to refactoring
with without doing the remodeling first
you will just base time and money you
need to fix your model first you need to
fix your understanding first and then
you can fix the code and I'm not saying
that these practices are bad I'm saying
they're just not a sufficient right so
let's see where we are
well we're not done it's just been 15
minutes so there has to be more left
well okay so I said to fix this problem
with technical debt we first had to fix
the model well how do we fix the model
what cost is modeling that and now we're
sort of back to square one in some sense
and this is just the start of another
sort of journey down trying to
understand what this these issues really
are so but before we do that I'd like to
tell you a small story so this is the
story of a fictional software company
called eQuest
any quest delivers a suite of products
for the horse owner so there's a
breeding module there's a transportation
module there's a feeding module anything
that you need to sort of be a
professional in the horse industry
whatever that is so you typically work
with entities like this and for some
reason this company request is a great
success and it's expanding so one day
your product owner comes and says we're
gonna use this we're gonna have this new
horse as well and it looks like this and
they say these horses are very strong
and they're stubborn so we'd like to
sort of have this as part of our our
software and it's quite easy to talk
about this because in the design
meetings everyone understands what you
mean when you say this short strong and
stubborn horse but it's a little bit
harder now now that you have this new
kind of course it's a little bit harder
to understand what people mean when they
say horse because sometimes they mean
horse like this horse and sometimes they
mean the horse and the new horse and for
this reason people start to invent sort
of qualifications like this is a regular
horse it is this typical horse or a true
horse even an old-fashioned horse or
even a horse horse
and that's fine so you sort of add some
properties your code if the horse is
short and it is stubborn then you have
the logic for this new kind of horse and
if it's not then you have the regular
horse and everything is fine a lot of
you reuse you go into production quite
soon everyone's happy but of course
there are bugs now why are there bugs
well it's the stupid users right because
some users have horses that are short
and they think also that their horses
are quite stubborn so they sort of tick
this oh yeah it's a stubborn horse and
then suddenly they got for the regular
horse they get the new horse logic and
they didn't want that so that's it's a
bug that's what you call the design
meeting and it turns out that this new
short and stubborn horse
they also say iha so that's something
you can rely on because the the other
horse is sort of regularly neigh but
these horses say uh-huh so you can sort
of fix your logic like that and now this
goes into production debug phase fix is
into production everyone's happy
in fact they are so happy that the
product owner says okay can I have a yet
another kind of horse this is a new new
horse and then you as a developer you
say okay what's what what are the
properties of this horse well it's it's
a kind of horse that is the offspring of
a regular horse horse and a short and
stubborn horse that goes AHA it's quite
simple in fact there is it has so many
properties similar to both the regular
horses and the other horses that you
could reuse a lot of the code of course
the logic looks a little bit worse now
and about this time is when you start to
say to your project owner we have some
technical debt in the code
now unsurprisingly there are buggies
which is kind of a disappointment
because you've worked quite hard to work
out that logic but it turns out that it
matters for some reason for some of the
code in some of the modules whether or
not it is the mother or the father that
is stubborn and strong and Gao ze ha
because it turns out that only one of
those combinations can have offspring so
it's very important for breeding and
you're not so happy at this point and
then sort of you know it goes on and on
there are still new horses yeah so as an
aside this sort of example is very
simplified right so it's and it's sort
of it jumps out at you what the concept
should be and it what is problematic
with that story is that it it sort of it
indicates that there is an answer to
that question what are the concepts we
should use so everything would work out
if we we would just work out that ok
there is something called a donkey there
is something called a mule and stuff
like that
well I recommend reading this article
called what if anything is a zebra which
goes into some detail in discussion
whether or not there is sort of this we
all know what a zebra is it's a striped
horse but is it really is it sort of
just one group of horses or although
it's not horses it's zebras but sort of
is it the same group at the sort of DNA
level is it just one kind of thing or
are they they're sort of horses in
between the different kinds of severs
there are because there's just not one
kind of zebra there are three kinds of
zebras so it's there one conceptual
group called the zebra very interesting
so important there is no truth to being
covered usually there are just more or
less useful models and it's sort of up
to us to
figure out what the useful models are
and this means that modeling is just as
much about defining what should be
useful for us as sort of uncovering some
truth out in the universe as an example
from that I would like to talk about
sort of my daily life at NRK TV so what
if anything is a TV show this is
something I think a lot about everyday
basically so here's the TV show and this
is a TV show of the kind that has sort
of a long narrative that goes across
multiple episodes right and it has sort
of well it starts that you want when you
want to see it you want to start at the
first episode and then you see the next
one and then you see the next one if you
see the last one first you spoil
everything but not all TV shows are like
this this is a TV show of documentaries
so we can watch any episode
independently that's fine and here's
another kind of TV show which tells the
Daily News and usually you don't binge
the daily news right you just you're
interested in the last one and that
matters when we sort of want to present
it to the end user and this is the kind
of TV show again usually you want to see
the last one this is a sort of a talk
show where the host has some guests and
you might want to see the last one or
you might want to see the one that
features someone you find interesting
but it gets worse because well this is
for the non Norwegians this is scum it
is basically our most popular TV show at
least for on demand TV and it's not just
video right is this online sort of
social media kind of things so there are
things happening on a web page
sometimes it's video sometimes it's
something else and it sort of challenges
the entire idea of what a TV show is in
fact we sort of we have this projection
from this into a more traditional form
with this half-hour episodes that goes
consecutively so that it resembles a
usual TV show but it's an interesting
thing because what
often countless creativity is
challenging the mental models you
already have what something is so
answering this question is very hard
well how many kinds of TV shows are
there well it which concept should we
used how can we enable ourselves to talk
precisely and how can we sort of know
that we're not in the position that
eQuest was in and it depends on what we
want to express and quite frankly are
the truth is that modeling is hard and
it's hard for two reasons and the first
is the stuff that's being modeled and
the second is just those doing the
modeling yeah look at each intern so
first let's look at the stuff that's
being modeled why is that hard why is
that so hard well in some sense reality
has no interesting being modelled really
a reality JJ's right so it's not tidy
and organized it's not even consistent
it tends to be messy and it slips away
it doesn't it doesn't want to be
contained and what we're trying to do
when we're modeling is imposed some
structure on something that's sort of
fundamentally unstructured and I
recommend this book it's from the 70s I
think called the day tree and reality by
William Kent and it talks about some
things that makes sort of reality hard
to turn into data and one thing is
identity so what does it mean for
something to be one thing and there are
lots of examples like that it's an
obvious example is it's like a book is
my copy of a book the same as your copy
of a book there is to serve sort of some
abstract notion of a book that
encapsulates all the all the concrete
books that are out there out there so
what's one thing and it depends again
right another thing is what is equality
what what does it mean that two things
are equal when are they the same and is
being equal and the same the same thing
it's terribly sort of philosophical
thing to think about and also change is
interesting so
if some things change when do something
that you previously consider to be equal
become different from each other and
finally how do we categorize things how
do we determine which category something
belongs to is it possible for a thing to
change category and is that event of
changing category is so significant that
it means that's become another thing so
if those things are interesting to you I
recommend reading that book another book
I recommend is one that's called women
fire and dangerous things by George
Lakoff and that talks more about
categorization now the classical theory
of categorization is based on properties
hmm and as sort of object-oriented
programming we are all familiar with
this theory of classification because
that's sort of the underlying idea
behind classes in languages like similar
that we saw this morning and c-sharp
and basically what it says that you have
some properties that are necessary and
sufficient to determine whether
something is member of a category now
what does a bird look like can you sort
of picture a bird in your head let's try
to do okay a bird just contrary contrary
it up in your head I'm sure you can do
it did anyone think of this bird yes
there's one they thought about that bird
how many thought about something like
this there are more they thought about
something like this we thought about
this one there is one they thought of a
shoe bill that's perfect it's one of my
favorite birds now the idea by this
thought experiment is that there are
some members that can be thought of as
more typical than others while being
members of the same category so in some
sense a sparrow is more birdy than a
penguin
and a sparrow is also more birdy than a
shoe bill now you could say you can
argue that okay but a sparrow is more
birdy than a penguin because a penguin
doesn't fly
well the shoe bill flies but a sparrow
is more common so that's why we sort of
think of that first in fact I was having
a discussion about this and I think
espero is probably the burliest bird
that there is and this is one of the
topics in this book by George Lakoff and
it has to do with something called
prototype theory that was introduced by
Eleanor Rosch in the 70s and I'm quite
convinced now you've heard about
classical inheritance and you've heard
about probably typical inheritance in
languages like JavaScript and self and
I'm quite convinced that Dave Unger was
aware of the work well in a rush and
that's why they have prototype based
inheritance itself and that's why you
have it in JavaScript but it's
interesting to think about how untypical
is to untypical to be a member of a
category when it is is it too unequal
when does the donkey become a donkey
well it depends again and certainly the
donkey doesn't care it just is whatever
it is right it's a horse it's a donkey
it's just something so we are the ones
who are trying to put things into
categories to make sense of reality and
this also means that generalization is
an hypothesis about the future so if you
sort of create a category for things
you're saying at the same time I'm
expecting things to have a certain set
of properties also in the future and
that's why you should be very very
careful by introducing artificial ad hoc
generalizations because you're betting
against the future right and with
someone's being creative like creating a
new kind of TV show or in our case it
might be that your bet was wrong and you
lose so the second thing why modelling
is hard
it's those doing the modelling so the
reality is doesn't want to be modeled
now who makes software and that's at the
same time asking the question who owns
the technical debt and is easy for us as
developers yeah well I'm the one typing
the code so I must be the one making the
software and of course the rest of the
organization would dearly love it for
bid for it to be the case that technical
debt is something that the developers or
the IT department owns and they don't
really have to care about it
but at the same time it's it's kind of
hard to ignore that the fact that the
organization is a part of the culture
that produces the software because they
sort of create the framework that their
software is written in and this is a an
excellent quote by a friend of mine who
says that if you remake awful software
from scratch without changing the
culture that created it you will remake
awful software now when discussion
discussing how organization affects
software you often hear people talk
about Conway's law who's heard of
Conway's law everyone or maybe not
everyone but at least quite a few of you
well it's an interesting exercise to
sort of go and read the actual paper to
see what he meant
so I recommend reading how to commit
this event by Mel Conway I think it's
it's just like four or five pages it's
not long and it's quite well-written and
it says some interesting things one
thing this says is that just by
organizing a team to solve some design
problem you have already made some
design decisions because there are some
decide there will be some design options
that cannot be effectively pursued by
the team that you assembled and given
this it's very interesting question how
agile the organization is will the
organization or the team that you set
out to solve a task be agile enough to
modify itself so that it gets solved a
task better is it is it able to identify
that it's not the optimal organization
to solve a problem
dissolve itself and then reform in a
shape that's more suited to solve the
problem that's quite hard and the second
thing is what's known as Conway's law
but that Conway calls the homomorphism
which is a fancy word and the question
you ask is is there a relationship
between the structure of the
organization and the structure of the
system that it designs and Conway's
answer is yes there is and in fact it's
a very very simple organization ship it
says that an organization tends to
produce self portraits in the system
that they create it means that if you
have an August organization that
consists of three teams you're going to
have a system that has three sort of
modules right one for each team it looks
just if you draw a graph of the software
it's going to be one to one with the
organization that produced it and for
that reason some people who want to
change the architecture of the system
figure out that okay we're going to try
to change the organization to fit the
architecture that we want for our system
and that can be a good idea but it's
very very hard to do in practice because
well organizations don't want to change
and also systems don't want to change
you had to work very hard at it and for
this reason Mathias has this core
corollary to Conway's law it says that
if you design a system but you didn't
design this organization to produce the
system then you're not the system's
designer you might think that you are
but if someone else determines the
structure of the organization you are
not the system designer so all these
points to the divide between business
and IT is very very problematic and in
some sense Conway Conway's law implies
that system architecture is Enterprise
Architect architecture and the other way
around
so well we've certainly come a very long
way from ugly code and it might be
worthwhile asking why do we still talk
about technical debt because these
things that we'll be talking about now
they're not technical at all well one
thing is that the consequences of all
these sort of issues are made manifest
and they're visible at the technical
level that's where do you have to see
them and it's also this thing that we as
developers have this tendency to sort of
look for technical solutions even to
solve problems one thing is that we
might know might not be aware of the
soft problems that influences and then
we sort of reach for for the solutions
that we know about but it's also that
the soft problems are really hard
problems probably the hardest problems
there are and technical tasks they are
very tempting and they're tempting
because sort of that's what we signed up
to do right it fits what we've been
trained to do it fits what we're good at
and they involve little in terms of
their psychology and politics and they
rarely lead to conflict I mean we can
argue over what library is the best or
what technology is the best or something
like that but but it's not that kind of
conflict the technical work is puzzle
solving whereas modeling work tends to
reveal tensions and conflict between
people and perhaps between different
parts of the organization things that
might be very hard to resolve and in
some sense if you take Conway's loss
seriously you might have to or
reorganize in order to be able to do
sort of the appropriate refactoring that
you should do and that might not be in
your power to decide right now
let's return to this question that we
had what makes a meme successful is it
the greatest explanation power or is the
idea that is most effective at reducing
cognitive dissonance it would be very
nice if technical debt were technical
because then we could solve it and we
didn't have to rely on other people to
help us solve it but I don't think there
are any technical solutions to technical
debt unfortunately and the reason is
that technical that isn't technical and
that's all I have thank you are there
any questions yes there is one question
what we should call technical debt and
that's a very good question
and in some sense what I want to sort of
do in this talk is to point at some
things we discussed too little with
respect to technical debt and I suppose
we could say that some technical that
really is technical and it has to be
like okay it's an obsolete library or
someone actually wrote crap code when
they should have been able to do a
better job and stuff like that so it's
sort of is a little bit of a hyperbole
hyperbole exaggeration perhaps to say
that's not technical at all but I think
at least we should be talking about
modeling that and we should be talking
about the consequences about of sort of
working with an implementation where we
don't really understand the prime
problem that we're solving well yeah yes
another question
[Music]